[Musique]
bonsoir aka benillouche merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur arte france
alors cette autorisation elle intervient
en pleine campagne électorale pour les
législatives du mois de mars rémi
netanyahu et benny ganz qui veulent
donner des gages aux colons et à leur
soutien selon vous la situation est
assez tendue netanyahu qui effectivement
d'après les sondages est en tête de tous
les partis avec eux en gros entre 28 et
32 sièges sur 120 mais il a une des
grandes difficultés à pouvoir créer une
coalition
il a deux concurrents directs issus
d'ailleurs les deux du likoud
le premier c'est d'un fanni bennett qui
est un jeu religieux sioniste qui est
très attaché aux colonies en israël et
d'autres en cisjordanie et d'autre part
vous avez guidéon saar qui vient à peine
de quitter le parti et qui fait partie
de la droite du likoud
donc ce sont donc deux opposants de
droite et donc d'un tas ou un besoin de
vider les sens de leur lever leurs
électeurs en faisant des en prenant des
décisions qui satisfont les éventuels
colons et donc à l'heure actuelle de
natanyahou et condamné est condamné à
faire la courte échelle à tous les
extrémistes de droite il y a trois
petits partis à l'extrême droite qu'il
est en train de convaincre de le
rejoindre
est ce qu'il veut c'est essentiellement
empêcher les deux parties de se réunir
pour lui prendre la place
alors donc il est prêt à tout il est
prêt à tout et il a donc fait cette
c'est cette décision de créer des
colonies la même choisi une un symbole
dans une des colonies
il y a quelques jours il
il ya eu un assassinat d'une femme qui
habitait dans une des colonies qui
s'appelait tél mais lâché et bien pour
punir les et les et les palestiniens qui
sont dans les environs eh bien il a
décidé de créer 100 logements dans cette
habitation une sorte de vengeance contre
l'al contre éventuellement contre l'
assassinat alors on ne pense jamais ni
leur donnez moi mais c'est intéressant
ce que vous nous dites pas ce que ça
consomme pas nécessairement tout et
population d'israël c'est une galère
vous l'avez expliqué politique comment
réagissent et les israéliens à cette
nouvelle par exemple les israéliens sont
je dirais un petit peu éteint je dirais
à l'heure actuelle ils ont toujours
parce que la majorité de la population a
viré à la droite pour ne pas dire à
l'extrême droite la gauche n'existe plus
le centre est a explosé en quatre ou
cinq unités
il ne peut plus gouverner et donc que ce
qu'on sait c'est que la population est
résignée la population est résignée elle
sait qu'elle ne pourra pas éviter
l'arrivée d'un gouvernement de droite
voire d'extrême droite parce que les
deux concurrents de natanyahou sont des
gens d'extrême droite dire qu'ils sont
d'extrême droite c'est qu'il refuse la
création d'un état palestinien
ils sont pour l'annexion total de la
cisjordanie
ils sont pour l'interdiction de donner
la nationalité israélienne aux futurs
habitants qui seraient annexés
et donc c'est vraiment l'ailé dure du
parti les couples qui viendrait au
pouvoir et de l'autre côté c'est d'être
querelles intestines
c'est la guerre des ego je dirais parce
que tout le monde veut être président de
parti
tout le monde de l chefs de partis et
ils voient pas l'intérêt que l'intérêt
primordial c'est de se lier contre
netanyahou et biens d'occasion vous
expliquer cette radicalisation de
l'opinion vous nous décrivez on sait
quand on sort de quatre ans de mandat
donald trump qui a été un grand grand
soutien envers benjamin netanyahu est ce
que ceci explique cela où ça n'a rien à
voir
et justement c'est parce que trump a
beaucoup aidé israël vous savez que
pendant la mandature de deux trains qui
a eu 27 mille logements qui ont été
créés et donc très mme c'était un peu le
dieu d'israël et le jour où il a été élu
ça a été je dirais une journée de deuil
parmi les populations de droite et donc
il est évident que pour eux ce que
faisait 30 était la meilleure chose pour
le pays et de l'autre côté
eh bien on peut dire que il n'y a pas eu
de réveil du centre ou de la gauche et
donc à partir de ce moment là le pays
est en train de virer de plus en plus
vers l'extrême droite
et malheureusement pour beaucoup de
populations du centre et de droite et
ivo pratiquement décidé certains de ne
pas aller voter parce qu'ils savent que
c'est sans issue
la situation est critique mais ils ne
sont pas prêts à voter c'est pour ça
qu'à l'heure actuelle il ya beaucoup de
deux parties qui essaient de raviver
l'élan de les populations pour leur
demander de voter et de ne pas baisser
les bras mais on ne peut rien faire
c'est la constatation qui se fait les
sondages donnent à peu près 60 au niveau
de la droite
plus de soixante cinq votants au niveau
du likoud très peu mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que si ça continue dans cette
danse ou telle forme et bien on va avoir
un gouvernement d'extrême droite dirigé
par naftali bennett et guidéon saar
auxquels se joindront quelques autres
partis du centre qui clôtureront la
coalition mais ils n'auront pas beaucoup
droit à la parole parce que le centre
n'existe plus la gauche n'existe plus
comme en france le parti travailliste a
disparu de l'écran de 2 des élections
des élections il ya juste un petit parti
d'extrême gauche ou de gauche historique
qui est le meretz avec cinq députés
il fera pas grand chose
non de marquer la présence continue
d'une ère gauche dans le pays
nous en sommes là et donc effectivement
nous virons de plus en plus vers
l'extrême droite et c'est un peu triste
pour beaucoup de gens de la population
de voir que c'est ce monde là qui dirige
accompagné accompagné il faut le dire
par les orthodoxes religieux qui eux
avec entre 16 avec 16 députés font la
pluie et le beau temps imposent leurs
lois imposent les lois à la coalition
imposent les lois à tous les
gouvernements qui sont là parce que
c'est eux qui sont le l'essence même de
cette coalition
merci jacques benillouche d'avoir été
avec nos journalistes indépendants en
direct d'israël pour vu de l'extérieur
ce soir